>> Laura: WE ARE COMING YOU
TONIGHT FROM LOS ANGELES IN THE
SANCTUARY STATE OF BEAUTIFUL
CALIFORNIA.
IT’S GROUND ZERO IN A SHOWDOWN
OVER ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
"THE SAN FRANCISCO CHRONICLE"
REPORTING THAT IMMIGRATION AND
CUSTOMS ENFORCEMENT IS ABOUT TO
LAUNCH MASSIVE IMMIGRATION RAIDS
ACROSS NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THE RAIDS WILL TARGET CRIMINALS
AND THOSE ALREADY SLATED FOR
DEPORTATION BUT LOCAL POLICE
DEPARTMENTS ARE REPORTEDLY NOT
PLANNING TO COOPERATE WITH THE
FEDS.
LET’S GO STRAIGHT TO THE SOURCE,
IMMIGRATION CUSTOMS ENFORCEMENT
DIRECTOR TOM HOLMAN JOINS US
FROM FREDERICKSBURG VIRGINIA.
DIRECTOR, THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US TONIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE AT GROUND ZERO FOR THE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION BATTLE.
YOUR AGENCY, THE IMMIGRATION
CUSTOMS ENFORCEMENT HAS SAID
THAT YOU ARE GOING TO BE
CARRYING OUT IMMIGRATION GRADES
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA SOON.
NO BIG SURPRISE, SOME OF THE
DEMOCRATS ARE NOT HAPPY ABOUT
THAT.
DIANNE FEINSTEIN AND KAMALA
HARRIS JUST WROTE YOU A LETTER
AND THEY SAID DIVERTING
RESOURCES IN AN EFFORT TO PUNISH
CALIFORNIA AND TO SCORE
POLITICAL POINTS IS UNIMPORTANT
ABUSE OF POWER NOT TO MENTION A
TERRIBLE MISUSE OF THE SCARCE.
HOW DO YOU RESPOND?
>> ISA DIDN’T ANNOUNCE ANY
OPERATION, WE DIDN’T ANNOUNCE
OPERATIONS IN ADVANCE OF THAT.
WHAT I DID SAY IS WE ARE GOING
TO INCREASE RESOURCES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN RESPONSE
TO THE POLICIES.
LET ME EXPLAIN THIS ISN’T A
THREAT TO CALIFORNIA, THIS ISN’T
A RETALIATION FOR LAWS.
WE USED TO HAVE ACCESS, ONE
OFFICER CAN SIT IN THE JAIL AND
PROCESSED TEN ILLEGAL CRIMINAL
ALIENS IN A SHIFT.
SINCE THEY ARE RELEASED TO THE
STREET, WE HAVE MORE RESOURCES
TO LOCATE THESE PEOPLE OUT IN
THE COMMUNITY.
IN A COUNTY JAIL THEY DON’T HAVE
ACCESS TO WEAPONS.
WE HAVE TO LOCATE THESE PEOPLE
ON THE STREET AND THEIR PLACE OF
BUSINESS.
WE NEED MORE OFFICERS OUT THERE
TO DO THAT JOB SAFELY.
ADDING RESOURCES, IS IN DIRECT
RESPONSE TO THE SANCTUARY LAWS
THAT FORCED ME TO BE IN THAT
POSITION.
AS FAR AS THE CONGRESSMAN WHO
WROTE THE LETTER, I DIDN’T THINK
CONGRESS WAS IN THE BUSINESS OF
ENACTING LAWS THEY DIDN’T WANT
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO ENFORCE.
I AM ENFORCING THE LAWS THAT
THEY ENACTED.
FOR THEM TO SAY I SHOULDN’T BE
ENFORCING THE LAWS, WE HAVE
TAKEN A SWORN DUTY AND ENFORCING
LAWS IN THIS COUNTRY.
WE HAVE ENFORCED THE LAWS THAT
CONGRESS ENACTED.
I’M DOING WHAT THEY TELL ME TO
DO.
I AM ENFORCING LAWS THAT THEY
HAVE ENACTED.
>> Laura: NOW THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS SAID THAT
THEY MAY TAKE ENFORCEMENT ACTION
AGAINST EMPLOYERS WHO ASSIST ICE
IN FINDING THESE INDIVIDUALS OR
GIVING INFORMATION TO ICE ABOUT
KNOWN ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
THE STATE MIGHT ACTUALLY GO
AFTER EMPLOYERS FOR WORKING WITH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND THEY
CITE THEIR PROTRACTION OF
IMMIGRANT ACTS WHICH WAS SIGNED
INTO LAW AND WENT INTO EFFECT
JANUARY 1ST OF THIS YEAR.
THEY WOULD THEN BE INTRUDING ON
THE PRIVACY OF THE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
THIS IS WHAT YOU ARE UP AGAINST,
YOU ARE UP AGAINST STATE
OFFICIALS WHO ARE THREATENING
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT OR
EMPLOYERS.
>> HE CERTAINLY KNOWS WHAT THE
LAWS IT SAYS, WE ARE ENFORCING
THE LAWS ENACTED BY CONGRESS.
IS THERE ANY OTHER FEDERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY WHERE
CONGRESSMAN OR ELECTED OFFICIALS
SAY DO NOT ENFORCE THE LAW?
NO ONE ASKS THE FBI NOT TO
ENFORCE THE LAW OF THE LOCAL
POLICE DEPARTMENTS.
WE ARE ENFORCING THE LAWS
ENACTED BY CONGRESS.
FOR THOSE THAT SAY THEY DON’T
WANT TO GIVE US ACCESS TO THESE
LOW-LEVEL CRIMINALS AND COUNTY
JAILS -- THE LOCAL POLICE
DEPARTMENT ARRESTED THESE
PEOPLE.
THEY LOCKED THEM UP IN THEIR
FACILITIES.
THESE AREN’T CHOIRBOYS, THESE
ARE PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
ARRESTED FOR CRIMES.
IF NOT FOR SERIOUS CRIMES, WHY
HAVE THEY BEEN ARRESTED?
>> PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN ARRESTED
AND DEPORTED, THAT HORRIFIC
STORY FROM TWO YEARS AGO, TWO
POLICE OFFICERS BRUTALLY
MURDERED BY ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS,
KILLED THESE BELIEFS OFFICERS
AND DEPORTED SEVERAL TIMES, WE
HAVE A SOUND BITE OF WHAT HE
SAID RECENTLY WHEN HE APPEARED
IN COURT, LET’S WATCH.
>> >> Laura: YOU SEE WHAT HE
SAYS, HE SAYS I KILLED THEM,
THEY ARE DEAD, IF I COULD, I
WOULD KILL MORE.
THIS IS WHAT THE FALLOUT IS OF
THE SANCTUARY STATE WIDE
POLICIES THAT HAVE BEEN IN
EFFECT.
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE STABBED
61-YEAR-OLDS WHO HAVE ALSO BEEN
DEPORTED.
YOU NEVER HEAR ABOUT THESE
THINGS, .
>> THEY ARE IN A COUNTY JAIL,
THEY’VE BEEN ARRESTED BY LOCAL
OFFICIALS, THEY THOUGHT THEY
WERE DANGEROUS TO THE COMMUNITY.
WHEN THEY ARE DONE WITH THEM,
WHY NOT LET THE FEDERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TAKE
CHARGE, NOT ONLY REMOVE THEM
FROM COMMUNITY BUT REMOVE THEM
FROM THE COUNTRY.
WHEN YOU ENTER THIS COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY YOU COMMITTED A CRIME.
>> Laura: THE LOCAL MAYOR OF
OAKLAND HAS TOLD REPORTERS THAT
HER POLICE IN HER CITY ARE NOT
GOING TO ASSIST YOU IN ANY
UPCOMING ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS, A
QUICK MESSAGE TO HER?
>> LET ME SPEAK NOT TO HER
BECAUSE I DON’T RESPECT HER
OPINION, I DON’T RESPECT WHAT
THEY DID.
LET ME SAY THIS TO THE MEN AND
WOMEN OF THE OAKLAND POLICE
DEPARTMENT -- FIRST OF ALL I’M
SAD YOU’VE BEEN PUT IN A
POSITION THAT A POLITICIAN WHO
WAS NEVER CARRIED A GUN AND
BADGE AND NEVER PUT THEIR LIFE
ON THEIR LINE, MAKE THESE
DECISIONS THAT AFFECT PUBLIC
SAFETY AND OFFERS        OFFICE.
IF YOU ARE DOING A LAWFUL
OPERATION AND THERE IS A NICE
AGENT WITHIN EARSHOT, WE WILL DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN WITH OUR LEGAL
AUTHORITY TO ASSIST YOU.
WE WILL DO EVERYTHING WE CAN AND